NICHOLE CLARKE: Hi,
I'm Nichole Clarke,
and my project is working
on developing the iOS
version of App Inventor
in order to democratize
cross-platform
mobile development.
Now, a big thing about
the App Inventor is that
it's block-based
visual programming,
and so that means that when
you're developing [? an ?]
[? Android ?] application, you
don't actually need to know
Java or anything of the like.
Now, when it comes
to iOS development,
there's still very
large barriers to entry.
One, you need to know Swift.
Two, you need to have
an iOS or Apple device,
such as a Mac laptop.
And three, the cost of owning
that device is pretty high.
So what we wanted to do
is develop and democratize
not only Android development,
but also iOS development.
And that's what my
project is working on.
I'm working on developing the
components for the iOS version
in the native language of Swift.
That way, what you're able to
do is take your existing App
Inventor project
and then compile it
into either an iOS
or Android device.
Now, what I worked on was
developing components.
And inherently there were
a couple of challenges
because the Android
version already existed.
For one, you want to really
keep the Android version
as the standard.
So it meant that when were
doing things like the map view,
we had to ensure that each
tile overlay match already
existed on Android.
And for iOS, that meant adding
in a custom tile overlay.
Additionally, we wanted things
like the accelerometer sensor
to use the same
coordinates, because it'd
be odd if you ran the same
app on iOS and Android
but one had up going this
way, and the other one
had positive going this way.
So you really need to
map that to be the same.
We also wanted to keep the same
human interfaces that Apple
had laid out already
and really not
have it feel as though you're
using something that wasn't
actually an iOS application.
Then lastly we had to deal
with permission handling, which
is dealing with
permissions at runtime
and accepting or rejecting
them to follow what Apple did.
Ultimately, we've had some
pretty good results, though.
By randomly selecting
1.8 million applications,
we're currently able to build
65.44% of the applications.
And let me put this
in perspective--
the Android version
of App Inventor
has been around for
eight years, and we just
began work on the iOS
version in this past year.
So I'd say we're
doing pretty well.